There are so many new beauty products
being released all the time,
so we gathered some of the most hyped
from the last month to test for ourselves.
First up we have the
Madluvv Brow Stamp Kit
that went viral on TikTok.
It comes with five
different-sized brow stencils.
You basically apply the
stencil to your brow
and stamp the brow color on to fill.
This was surprisingly easy to use,
and it is kind of fun to,
like, stamp on a brow.
I think I applied a little too much
of the brow color, but
I liked how it looked
after diffusing the
color with the spoolie.
My brows are a little
sparse but naturally full,
so I think a product like this
is definitely better for people
with little to no brow hair.
I am so torn on my feelings
for this Rimmel mascara.
The brush is a very spiky plastic
that kind of hurt my
eyes when I was applying.
I didn't like that at all.
And the actual mascara formula
is so weird and gloopy,
but after applying it, I think I liked it.
It definitely lengthened my lashes a lot,
and it didn't get too clumpy
when I was layering it up.
It didn't do too much for
me in terms of thickening,
which is mainly what I
look for in a mascara.
But if you're someone who wants length
from a mascara, you'd like this.
But be aware of the really spiky brush.
Colourpop came out with
a new lipstick formula,
the Glossy Lip Stain.
I was kind of blown away by this.
The color is so rich and vibrant.
I don't know why I
expected it to be sheer,
but it's definitely not.
There was a slight
patchiness that went away
with another swipe of the product.
The texture is thinner
than I would expect from a gloss
and has a slightly tacky finish,
which I didn't mind.
And before it dries
down, it does transfer.
Here's what it looked
like a few hours later
when it was pretty dried down.
The stain it leaves behind is so pretty
and gives you those, like, Popsicle lips.
Once it dries down,
it's pretty transfer-proof.
I love this, and I will definitely
be buying some more shades.
I love Melt Cosmetics,
and I was totally mesmerized
when I saw these new liquid highlighters
they were releasing,
especially this pink one.
I literally never wear pink highlighter,
but this color was just speaking to me,
and I had to have it.
The glow these give is intense.
It looks really good on bare skin.
Not super natural,
but not glittery or too metallic.
I also love it over my foundation.
It didn't break anything up,
and it layered really well.
You can also wear these on the body
or mix them into your foundation
to make it more glowy.
These are pricey,
but because you can wear
them in so many ways,
I think it's worth it.
I am so not a cream-bronzer
kind of person,
but I've been seeing them everywhere.
This one from E.l.f. has
been getting great reviews,
and it's super affordable,
so I had to try it.
The texture is hard to describe,
because it blends from a cream to this
supersoft diffused,
almost powderlike finish.
What scares me about cream bronzer
is it not being blendable
and not meshing well with my foundation,
but this one was so blendable
and easy to work with,
and you can definitely layer it
if you want to build up the color.
I love this.
I had to get this Flower Beauty
spray-can setting spray.
I honestly thought this
was going to go terribly.
You basically just shake it up
and spray it all over your
face to set the makeup.
Honestly, it wasn't that bad.
It did set and matteify my face nicely.
It didn't have a strong smell,
which I was worried about,
and it didn't spray powder everywhere.
What I don't like about it is that
it's hard to use in concentrated areas
like my under-eyes.
It didn't set that area very well,
and I saw my concealer
creasing pretty quickly.
I think this could be good for touch-ups,
like getting rid of
oil throughout the day,
but not for actually setting your makeup.
Also, the spray is ...
it's a little aggressive.